it's officially the one year anniversary
of starting this show and we want to
thank all of you for sticking with us so
to celebrate this time we're going to
explore the lands above and beyond and
break the boundaries of breath of the
wild as usual let us know if you want to
keep learning new things by liking this
video
you can easily break open or burn wooden
boxes to get the goodies inside but you
can never do the same to metal chests
they never break but did you know
there's actually one way to do this
death mountain's cannon can completely
destroy metal chests and drop the loot
inside
even amiibo armor
well that's just weird without any sort
of mods it's actually possible to go
into space in breath of the wild albeit
with a lot of prep work first by first
performing a complex glitch called
memory storage then performing another
glitch called inventory corruption you
can get 80 000 arrows basically the
amount of fuel you need to break the
atmosphere then by performing more
glitches such as apparatus storage then
jumping in a death mountain getting moon
jump then pulling out a bomb arrow will
start your journey slowly towards the
stars you can even sort of see the edge
of the atmosphere from up here
and remember many episodes ago when i
said that maybe we'll be able to grab
that shock arrow one day well for glitch
hunters if there's a will there's a way
and this technique also lets you grab
that impossible shock arrow
easy peasy previously i've shown this
mysterious apple tree behind dog choco
shrine placed here for seemingly no
reason but did you know that there's
actually more stuff even farther back
behind the shrine using a couple
glitches you can walk freely around the
lost woods for a short time and if you
head farther back into the lost woods
you can actually find a hearty truffle
and two razor shrooms hanging out back
here completely impossible to get
through normal gameplay between the
beehive apples mushrooms and truffles
all out of reach it's theorized that
nintendo was building the space to be a
playable area then abandoned it and
completely forgot to remove these assets
[Music]
did you know that there are several
places in gerudo town that are safe for
you to stand in without a disguise
besides the obvious gerudo secret club
you can climb inside the southeast gate
on top of the waterway
the two cornerstones
and straight over the wall on the
northwest gate
did you know that you can lift up large
barrels like this with rivoli's gale
and even go for a little ride on it this
can extend your gale's reach
you can even walk backwards on it as
well like in the circus
there's a couple ways to escape the
borders of hyrule but out here as you'd
expect there isn't much of anything but
you can reach this unreachable mountain
far east of hyrule
did you know that almost all the gerudo
and hyrule greet you accordingly to the
time of day
[Music]
good morning good evening and good night
before starting any conversation even
frida the traveling rito learning gerudo
responds in the same way
for some players it was really obvious
to try to enter this fake doorway but
others may not know about the secret
gerudo club interaction
spear liners are often known for doing a
jumping plunge attack against link but
sword and crusher lynels are able to do
this as well and they have their own
special animation for it
there's a grassy plateau far west of
hyrule impossible to reach because of
its high winds and void out areas but by
using blss to zip through the wind
before it gets a chance to load in you
can access the hidden plateau
[Music]
this area even spawns dynamic enemies
just like anywhere else in hyrule
did you know said on can be knocked out
by pushing him out of the zora domain
you can have enemies attack him and
knock him out even though he's never in
a combat situation like this during
normal gameplay nintendo still coded the
dialogue and animations of him being
knocked out and recovering just in case
when talking to selmy the shield surfer
she lets you take a shot at shield
surfing down heber mountain to race
against a time but sometimes she'll
comment on what shield you have equipped
on your back which happens with only six
specific shields the steel lizard
dawnbreaker
radiant shield
gerudo shield
royal shield
and her least favorite the royal guard
shield
very early in the development of breath
of the wild many npcs were still in the
concept and design phase not ready at
all for implementation so to work around
this nintendo used older assets in their
place until the npcs were ready this
photo shows breath of the wild link
interacting with mila from wind waker in
place of riju and greba from skyward
sword acting as bulliara this would have
been an amazing crossover did you know
that it's possible to cut down a tree
with a spear well at least moblins can
not link blink spear attacks are all
poking attacks never able to cut a tree
but maublin's swings are so strong they
can even cut a tree down with the weak
vocal spear not even mccoblin and
lizolfos are capable of doing this
nintendo was pretty ambitious when it
came to designing horse behaviors and
many cute ideas were unfortunately cut
likely due to them being too difficult
or not important enough to implement
from this small list here only two made
it which were eating items and shaking
when getting out of the water they also
wanted cheek nuzzling dancing with music
a playful run tree branch eating and
sticking its head through a house window
probably inspired by the beginning of
skyward sword
there are a ton of examples through the
game checking if you did something out
of order and reacting accordingly
like in the zora domain there's a
separate cutscene for meeting the zora
king before beating sidon and an extra
zelda cutscene if you never met imba
first
did you know that you could stand on top
of korok balloons
[Music]
have you wanted to see what one of these
korok flowers look from underneath well
here you go
pretty much any zelda fan who's watched
speed runs have heard of the infamous
super swim which lets you swim at
ridiculous speeds but by clipping
through the ground moon jumping clipping
through the water layer by shield
jumping and waiting for link to fall
through the water layer then jumping
back up to touch the water later again
this triggers breath of the wild's
version of a super swim
the strange thing is it even has key
similarities to wind waker's version
such as holding the opposite direction
to go forward and splashing if you stop
too quickly
most npcs cower and fear of monsters but
moza the terrible cook is capable of
putting up a fight since she has
equipped weapons if pushed far enough
this ladle and pot wielding hylian can
hold her own against dangerous monsters
or maybe not
previously i've shown that if you quick
menu while turning towards a shop item
you can see some really strange numbers
appear for everyday items this actually
shows something that's pretty
interesting behind the scenes this was
the default template they used in the
proprietary version of a program you can
purchase called layout editor as seen
here that has the same double overlay
text on top the extra stamina wheel the
same star and 100 base attack this
program apparently saved them a lot of
time in production as normal production
consists of creating the asset checking
the viewer implementing it into the game
then checking if it works properly but
in this case they were able to make the
item then immediately reflect it in the
game they sure know how to be efficient
one year later and we're still on the
never ending quest to find breath of the
wild secrets if you enjoyed this series
let us know and check out our other
breath of the wild content including
breakdown of today's advanced combat and
easy tricks you can learn yourself for
anything else gaming stay right here on
gamespot
[Music]